You make a mistake and it's brought up against you 30 years later to keep you
out of public office when you might've grown enormously as a human being.
I think we need to see civility actually as a tough minded virtue
that says picking up on the old, um, Evelyn Beatrice, whole idea,
uh, that I may disagree with you, but I'll defend to the death,
your right to say it implies two things.
I'll respect you enough to say you have a right to put your ideas on the table
and then the ideas or the issue,
because that's where we'll get the best way forward.
It's not for me to demonize you. I don't like your ideas, but absolutely.
You've got the right to put them on the table. Let's throw those out.
Now it's an equal playing ground because that's not the way the games being
played, but I don't see any option. And even people like Gandy sort of,
kind of got that. Didn't he? I mean,
it's about forgiveness at something's washing out of our culture and you know,
I don't know how relationships ever work if we can't forgive.
And I think we have to be prepared to practice that and say, look, it's okay,
I'm sorry I was offended, but that doesn't matter. Let's move on.
Rather than this perpetual, I will carry the offense to the grave.
And that's the other great problem we've got in our culture because we, even,
if you can try and forgive, now,
you can't forget because social media is stored up. Absolutely everything.
So that's also the interesting part is that the asymmetry of the rules I think
is what's becoming harder and harder for conservatives. So for example,
Justin Trudeau can show up in blackface.
I don't think most people think he's a true racist by any stretch.
He did something stupid. It was, you know, times change all of those things.
You know, we've had the governor here, Ralph Northam also, you know,
blackface 30 years ago, but he's a Democrat.
And the point is that they're both still in power while we know if these were
conservatives or Republicans or whatever, they would be destroyed. And then,
so then because of that, well, because of that,
then we see the conservatives going, no, we have to destroy them too.
And that's, I think that's the impulse that you're saying, no,
we have to fight that impulse. Yeah.
I, I believe that's right. I mean, I think there, the, uh,
the point would be to go to the frankly, the hypocrisy of it and highlight that,
but they're trying to avoid doing, you know,
the triumphalism remember the lessons when we stop burning one another at the
stake at the heart of this unique model of Western harmony,
where we learnt to live with one another's deepest differences was a willingness
to respect another person's conscience and let them live truly to that Constance
as long as they are not damaging other people.
And I don't mean by that occasionally offending people,
this idea that you can't give a fence. And that is that,
that is a way to shut down debate if ever there was. And,
you know, um,
if I'm honest about my life at times in which I've grown up in the times when
I've been grossly offended,
because somebody else has told me something about me,
I haven't wanted to hear and I've had to grow out of it, you know, um, that, um,
Jonathan height makes that point. You know, we tell our kids,
we bring them up to believe, um, that, um,
uh, what doesn't kill you will make you weaker. He says,
actually we need to build resilience. And when we get the setbacks,
we've got to learn from them and not just be like a plastic cup that you drop on
the floor and recovers its shape.
We actually need to be people when we've had a setback who grow,
he calls it anti-fragility and our parents and grandparents believed that.
And look at what the great generation as you call them in this country went
through.
So is that just all then a function of our success that our parent you're right.
Our parents, our grandparents went through it, grandparents,
particularly at least in an American context. And because of that,
because of that grit and fight that,
then they sort of got us to unprecedented wealth,
a growing middle-class in the United States. And what happened? Well,
we got participation trophy.
Yeah. I think you might be right. And maybe it took, I mean,
I grew up with a father who had a horrendous second world war, uh, and, uh,
I was born quite late in his life. Uh,
and so I always lived with a man had seen war he'd volunteered, hated it,
you know, could never talk of,
it was almost killed in the campaign against Rommel, um,
in the Western desert and that's shaped me.
But then I'm conscious that I had a desire with my four
children to want to snowplow for them. There was a tendency was there.
I wanted to remove every obstacle in a way that my father didn't try for me.
He knew instinctively that a few challenges were a good thing for me.
And I knew that too,
but I had to pull myself back cause the instinct all the time was to make it
soft and easy. And I think Jonathan Heights, right, it doesn't work.
And he goes on to say that we then encourage children to trust their feelings.
Your feelings are always right. We know that's not right.
You have to think things through your feelings must accord with reality.
It's just dangerous. The field somethings, or I feel that water would be nice.
And that the science saying that there are sharks in there,
shouldn't be getting in the way of me having a good swim, you know?
And then the other one,
this problem gets to the heart of what we're talking about.
We teach our children that the dividing line between good and bad is between
people or that bad life is a battle between good and bad people.
That's a disaster to disaster. Yeah.
Most people on the other side believe that they're good too. They may be wrong.
Well,
not only that we're all a mixture and why can't we go on a journey even right.
Quite a bit about how you've been on a journey politically. Yeah. Well,
isn't that a good thing, you know,
to think things through and to learn from your mistakes. Um,
forgive me, it's not for me to say that you made mistakes or whatever,
but I know.
I have absolutely made mistakes. I promise you.
Now in the lexicon of those who hold the microphones in our society,
and you see that with social media, the thing we're talking about earlier,
who make a mistake,
and this brought up against you 30 years later to keep you out of public office,
when you might've grown enormously as a human being,
and you might've asked those that you heard or that you've mischarged,
but what are the mistakes you made for forgiveness?
You grow up in a normal city, you've come to a different place.
Why should we not respect them?
Do you think, oddly though,
that the end of secularism leads us to that place of unforgiveness,
do you think that is sort of what you were talking about earlier that if you
remove all of whatever traditional belief there is that you will end up in a
place that will be so subjective,
that how would forgiveness even make sense in that world?
That sort of seems to me where we're sort of at, at the moment. Yeah.
I mean, this is a great thing. Now it's all about power.
Everyone talks about power, but it's, it's very inadequate.
Douglas Murray says it.
If you walk up and most people in the street and say what most matters to you
most, they won't say power.
They'll talk about love that talking about relationship. And so,
but I think relationship in the Western model draws an enormous amount from
our understanding of that thing called the cross and the central message.
There was a death, um, a life's rendered,
uh, for enemies out of love, loving your enemies.
We can't even love our friends half the time. Yeah.
We need to learn to love our enemies again,
which is why I think I'm all for vigor in debate. I love what you do.
I love what Jordan Peterson does. I love what, so, I mean,
this is a big part of the picture.
You've got an enormous intellectual vigor coming back into Western life
and that's tremendously encouraging.
And it's an enormous privilege just to pay a tiny little bit. You know,
I hope in facilitating that with my own website, for example, and so forth.
But I see this as tremendously encouraging, but we've,
we've got to break the very model.
That's brought us to us in the first books to that place in the first place,
which is the rejection of the idea of respect and recognition of the worth and
dignity of others.
Are you amazed how this is a truly worldwide phenomenon right now?
So that's why I started the interview by saying that, you know,
you sent me this email three years ago and then, you know,
flash forward basically, uh, two and a half years,
and I'm in Australia and I'm doing this event with you and everyone in that room
knew who I was and now most of them were there for Jordan.
And I can see that point,
but the basic idea that what we're talking about in America
is the same thing you're talking about in Australia.
It's the same thing they're talking about France,
and they're talking about it in Mexico.
It's not purely a Western society idea anymore. It's everywhere. Now.
It is, it is indeed. And a couple of observations. Uh,
the wealthiest countries in particular,
where it's been very easy for a long time, have lost sight.
I think of the idea of suffering and suffering can be very
instrumental in determining character and resilience, uh,
and compassion for others because you understand,
we've got rid of the idea that suffering, um, you know,
is part of life. We try to pretend we can build perfect society,
which is why people make unreal demands on government. You know,
we don't need gardening or none of that stuff. We don't need suffering anymore.
So Mr. Congressman, I expect you to solve every year, give me everything,
give me everything.
And Mr. Congressmen has been unwise enough to often if there's a congressmen
listening, please say,
I can say exactly the same about what I was presented or a Senator in Australia.
We have senators just like you do. Uh, we have a wash minster,
a house of representatives based on the British house of commons.
Our Senate is modeled exactly on your sentence. So we call it a wash. Um,
and we we've just got to break that cycle again and rediscover some routes or,
or this is the one that, you know,
conservative doesn't believe that the people who have gone before them were
lesser,
but our culture now seems to think that those who went before us had nothing to
teach us. That is a fatal.
If you're looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about politics,
instead of nonstop yelling, checkout our politics playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
watch our full episode playlist, all right, over here,
and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.